more than 2,000 inmates in the United
States have been exonerated and released
from prison since 1989 on May 15th of
this year David Robinson joined them and
walked out of a Missouri prison Robinson
had been given a life sentence but the
Missouri Supreme Court overturned his
murder conviction for a 48 hours
correspondent Erin Moriarty has been
following Robinson's story she went to
Sikeston Missouri to find out how he is
doing Erin good morning good morning it
mates who are paroled get help with
housing and finding employment but if
you're innocent and get released you're
often on your own getting back his life
has been much tougher than David
Robinson expected later on the night of
May 15th David Robinson walked out of
prison into the arms of his waiting
mother
Jeannette Makassar when he come out that
sale I just was stunned didn't know what
to say know what the think rat did but
it took some time for Robinson to
actually feel free
what made you really feel you were out
well I seen my mother my family our time
invisible maybe touch him physically but
uh to go pay respect to my grandfather
grade one month later Robinson made
another dramatic walk down the aisle
cheered on by his lawyers family and
friends David Robinson married longtime
girlfriend Pat Jackson who never gave up
on him during the 18 years he was
incarcerated I knew she could've
probably moved on in fact I asked him to
was he wasn't I mean you must really
love this guy to stick with him as long
as you have yes ma'am I do
yes ma'am I do she wasn't sure this day
would ever come
Robinson had been serving life for the
2000 murder of a young mother Sheila box
there was no physical evidence tying
Robinson to the crime just the testimony
of two government informants who later
admitted they lied
and in 2004 another man romance Mosby
confessed to shooting the victim during
a botched drug deal but this past
February a special master appointed by
the Missouri Supreme Court ruled what
Robinson had been saying all along that
he was an innocent man today
Robinson's in a world he no longer
recognizes when David was first arrested
Bill Clinton was president and Amazon
was a book company and now says
Robinson's lawyer Jonathan Potts he's a
middle-aged man with nothing he had no
money in his pocket
he didn't have a home he didn't have
credit essentially you're being reborn
Jackson Robinson a nurse says just
getting her husband and ID card was a
challenge and a bank accounts you can't
have a bank account because you have to
have your residence for six months
established and and how do you explain
where you weren't for the past six
months yes ma'am and then you have the
other hurdles like health insurance one
of the questions that they ask is have
they been incarcerated so you have a
harder time getting health insurance the
couple now lives in Sikeston Missouri
where Robinson is looking for a job but
applications are all online and it's a
little slow going
and while Robinson has left prison it
hasn't quite left him we were in a
department store shopping for something
to wear you know to the wedding he had
paid for his stuff but the clerk forgot
to take off the sensor and so once he
went you know to the door then the alarm
started going off and so he threw his
hands up in the air his instinct was I
didn't do it Robinson knows the odds of
stain-free are against him but he's
determined to beat them well the
grandfather said you could have called
me a young fool but you know carving an
old fool so i'ma start the rest of my
life living it different than I did
other part of my life
so Robinson went into prison at 32
he's now 50 years old and here's the
kicker for inmates in Missouri who are
freed because of DNA tests proved their
innocence their state fund she get fifty
dollars a day but for Robinson released
after a judge determined a detective
bungle this case nothing nothing you're
saying even paroled inmates get a better
deal than what's he gonna do well it can
sue he has a really great case I mean
there's a 53 page judgment by this judge
who talks about what had happened in
this case but it could take years
he has no marketable skills because
because he was considered a dead man
walking he wasn't allowed to take
classes in in jail in prison so and a
guy confessed in 2004 so I've known it's
why I did this story it was very very
disturbing it shouldn't have specially
I'm so glad I did Erin this yes or and
it's great to see it you know keep being
little keep reporting a thing I will get
an eye on him love her the new hero in
the story you can hear Erin continue the
discussion of David Robinson's case on
our CBS this morning podcast she shares
how she came across Robinson's story and
the challenges he faces going forward